tropical diseases affect more than a
billion people in 149 countries around
the world but of the 1500 new drugs
developed between 1975 and 2004 only 21
were for tropical diseases just about
one percent of the total why a lot of
these diseases don't start getting
research and development dollars until
they start affecting patients and rich
countries Ebola is not at all unique in
that respect there are many many
diseases including Chagas sleeping
sickness malaria that all lack really
modern effective treatments precisely
because they affect patients primarily
in poor countries where the patients
don't represent a market that motivates
pharmaceutical companies to develop the
drugs fundamentally while many
governments and many individuals put
forward the idea that all lives are
equal that's not how we practice in the
world looking at the HIV epidemic it
took us far too long to get drugs that
we had that we could have been producing
generically and millions died as a
consequence so we do unfortunately live
in a world where the lives of people in
wealthy countries are more valued
we've set up a system that at present
awards research and development that's
focused on diseases that rich people
suffer from there's no magic reason the
system has to be this way it's not a law
of nature one major idea has been to
offer prizes rather than having a patent
monopoly that lasts for 20 years you
would offer a large prize that would
focus on how much impact a particular
drug has on the health of a population
that way if you did come up with a
treatment for say Chagas disease or
sleeping sickness or a better treatment
for malaria or tuberculosis even you
would receive a prize and then that drug
would be available generically want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now